did you watch the logan paul
mayweather fight yeah i don't know who
didn't did anyone not
i think the question is who did not
watch the logan paul wit mayweather
fight who are you asking
i don't anyone in the back room is there
any did you guys all watch it
ladies anyway logan paul who is a
uh started on vine became a huge
youtuber has been very controversial
with his brother
for years doing things and crossing the
line
i think there's a big difference too
between because logan
paul had a lot of controversy he was
looked at
kind of not as the greatest guy i think
but he called himself he said
he said i'm tired i don't want to be
such a dick he said that those are his
words
right so i think he turned it around
a little bit for i mean i don't know i i
don't follow that because i'm a parent
and i'm focused well i do follow i do
follow and and so this is what this is
my this may be a little bit
controversial but this is what i think
i think first of all mayweather is
probably in the top five fighters of
all time what i have to say about the
fight
is i like logan
now so much more after the fight than i
did going into the fight
but that being said i i didn't feel
any of it was real i don't know if you
saw it and logan came out and talked
about it but all over the internet now
they're saying that logan
actually got kind of knocked out
and mayweather held him up to keep going
the extra rounds
well that's what i'm saying so i'm
saying that
what he did was they both created an
amazing payday
you know but that wasn't a real fight
and it wasn't a real fight because of
mayweather
mayweather said okay i'll take 100
million i'll avoid getting hit in the
face because
nobody has the skill to really knock me
down
and i'll get sweated up he didn't even
practice the way logan practiced
i'll take i would do what mayweather did
logan won
because one what he needed because he's
got the notoriety and he had the click
bait of just being able to show up in
the
uh in the ring and make it eight rounds
but it's not really making it eight
rounds
of you know mayweather at the top of his
game
mayweather never took it really
seriously logan took it seriously but
logan didn't know what he was getting
into
mayweather knew what he was getting into
you know you want
if you want to give me a hundred million
dollars
to just stand around and i will give you
a show and i believe that maybe he stood
him up i believe that maybe he didn't
give him that power punch that would
have knocked him over
because doesn't he get more money if he
went all eight rounds did he get more
money for going
the entire that's a good question but
i think the the fight was put on there
you're talking about there yeah look he
totally held him up he did one hit there
there's a hit logan is falling down
you're right you're right he would have
gone down you're right